[Music]  after a lifetime of being the world's  most famous enemies  [Music]  tom and jerry are about to start over  cause that's what friends are supposed  to  do  in the big city  this hotel has been host to four  presidents three popes two kings  and we're about to host the wedding of  the century do you think you're  qualified to take on this position  i shine under pressure like a diamond or  rihanna  one other thing  we have a mouse problem with the what  now i'll catch it sir  everybody gonna shine  like this don't even gotta try oh wow  this is so detailed  we could hire an exterminator or we can  leverage  millions of years of predatory evolution  if a picture of these mouse is tweeted  up to insta book face or ticky talk  we will be ruined no sir that's not  gonna happen  that rodent is toast  i will not let this hotel be ruined by a  cat and a mouth  he's dying on us  i think i might have just pulled this  [Music]  off  oh